A conman named Victor Lustig sold the Eiffel
Tower.
Twice!
In the mid-1960s, Slumber Party Barbie came
with a book called "How to Lose Weight."
One of the tips was "Don't eat."
Nasa is developing 3D printed pizzas for astronauts.
Because news traveled so slow back then, slaves
in Texas didn't know they were free for more
than two months after Lincoln issued the Emancipation
Proclamation which declared that all slaves
are instantly freed.
The first escalator in Britain was in Harrods
in 1889.
The trip on the escalator was so scary for
most folks that Harrods employed an attendant
to stand at the top of the escalator with
brandy and smelling salts to calm down the
customers after a terrifying ride.
Calvin Klein's Obsession for Men is used by
researchers to attract animals to cameras
in the wilderness.
In 1962, The U.S. government detonated a hydrogen
bomb in space called “Starfish Prime”,
that was one hundred times more powerful than
Hiroshima.
In Utah, it is against the law to fish from
the back of a horse
Prairie dogs have such a complex communication
system that they can accurately describe predators
with their calls, they even have a specific
call for a man with a gun.
Marie Curie's notebooks are still radioactive.
Researchers hoping to view them must sign
a disclaimer.
Sleeping through winter is hibernation, while
sleeping through summer is estivation.
The Playboy bunny costume was the first service
uniform to be registered with the U.S. Patent
and Trademark Office.
Antartica is punishingly cold but it's not
all ice and snow.
About 1,200 square miles of the continent
is made up of “dry valleys” where mountains
and ridges keep out precipitation.
Right now over 70% of people who are driving
on highways are speeding.
Astronauts aboard the international space
station witness around fifteen sunrises and
sunsets every day.
After Leonardo da Vinci's death, King Francis
I of France hung the Mona Lisa in his bathroom.